für dieses video brauche ich definitiv
erst mal auch balance bay
ich glaube es gehört hey leute jetzt
wieder mal waren und bekommt zu einem
neuen video von mir
wir müssen reden also ich muss reden und
wir müssen wir definitiv zu hören also
müsst ihr nicht schaltet weg wenn ihr
nicht wollt ich gerade mein fuß gekratzt
und dann in meiner nase super um meine
füße sind sauber also fast ich muss mit
euch reden im letzten video habe ich
ausprobiert und natürlich ist bei vielen
negativ angekommen negative energien
aber auch viele positive und viele leute
die gesagt haben
go for it wenn es dir besser geht damit
oder wenn es dir gut tut dann alles klar
und dann gab es gleich ein paar die
dachten das ist so ein jahr guck mal
hier die ganzen amazon link
ich will euch das verkaufen das war
definitiv nicht
ich hatte wirklich vor dieses diese
zeremonie zu machen und sage ich jetzt
auch im urlaub war und nicht so viel
content gekommen ist dachte ich okay
dann verbinde ich das gleich mal und
trainer stan und ich muss auch sagen ich
finde das video extrem lustig geworden
und mir hat er schnitt voll spaß gemacht
und es war seit langem mal wieder dass
ich am schnitt auch wirklich saß und
nicht die ganze dachte ich kann nicht
mehr
deswegen hat es nicht gesehen hab ich
jetzt gerne an es ist unglaublich
es tut mir leid falls ihr
hintergrundgeräusche hört aber hier wird
gerade überall da vorne mit rasen gemäht
hinten wird die straße aufgerissen also
sorry ich hab mir eine regel für dieses
video aufgesetzt und zwar dass ich bloß
nicht anfange zu weinen weil ich nicht
will dass es so ein video wird ich habe
jetzt aber schon lange für mich behalten
beziehungsweise jetzt auch im letzten
video gesagt und panikstörungen ich
erzähle ich vielleicht mal etwas darüber
und ich merke dass ich euch nie davon
erzählen werde beziehungsweise nie mich
zu dem thema mal öffnen werde wenn ich
nicht einfach mich mal hinsetzen und die
kamera anmache und heute morgen bin ich
aufgestanden und wollte wieder mit
meinem normalen content loslegen und ich
habe viele wie schmeckt's videos und und
sachen die ich nach machen möchte sagen
dich retten möchte ihr schickt mir auch
immer volle guten ideen was ich ja auch
super finde und ich hab auch ich bock
drauf wie schmeckt ist und die ganze
kochen
cocktails machen das ist so leicht nicht
gleich zu produzieren aber es fühlt sich
so leicht an weiß auch sehr kindlich ist
und viel neugierde und und spaß hat und
ja es ist einfach schön ist zu machen
aber ich habe das gefühl ich kann
irgendwie noch nicht so damit loslegen
weil ich noch so dieses unausgesprochene
habt beziehungsweise denke ich immer ich
muss mich erklären oder erklären warum
ich gerade so bin wie ich bin aber
eigentlich ist alles in ordnung denn auf
einem kanal funktioniert ja alles nur
das irgendwie extrem wenig videos kommen
also für meinen geschmack ich würde
natürlich viel mehr produzieren wollen
und ich hab damals angefangen vor
ungefähr jetzt fünf jahren mit youtube
und ich habe sofort die rolle der happy
vanessa eingenommen die ich aber auch 90
prozent der zeit bin ich bin so wie in
meinen videos ich bin immer am lachen
ich habe spaß ich nehm das leben
irgendwie nicht so richtig ernst ich
liebe weihnachten ich liebe ostern für
mich könnte halloween jetzt nicht
schnell genug kommen obwohl ich auf den
sommer haben will aber ich freue mich
jetzt schon auf halloween und ich habe
immer diese kindliche und fröhliche
seite an mir gemacht nur das ist halt
manchmal einfach nicht da und mein job
ist aber dass ich das bin und natürlich
sagt dir dann auch du kannst ja auch so
sein wie du willst und wir mögen dich so
wie du bist und ich glaube ich habe mit
meiner community und meinen zuschauern
auch das größte glück weil ihr einfach
so seid wie ihr seid und eigentlich auch
keinen druck macht aber dann lese ich
doch immer kommentare dazwischen wie ich
hab dich wegen dem wie schmeckt's videos
abonniert und jetzt kommt so was jetzt
bei dem esoterik video und natürlich
klar wenn ich daran denke wenn ich
kanäle abonniere und sie dann plötzlich
nicht mehr das machen was ich mir so
gerne anschaue dann bin ich auch
enttäuscht weil natürlich das was man
sich gerne anschaue dass wir noch haben
und man will ja nicht jemanden sehen der
irgendwie ein pendel hin und her
schwingen was ich damit sagen möchte ist
dass es halt schon schwer als diese
rolle immer einzunehmen
nachdem oder was mir so in den letzten
monaten passiert ist
ich bin nicht weil ich meine gehabt
diese helicobacter sache ja mitbekommen
ich hatte vor zwei jahren oder drei
jahren hat es angefangen oder vor vier
jahren schon mittlerweile dass ich mich
ständig übergeben musste dass meine
verdauung überhaupt nicht funktionierte
das ich krämpfe mit noch die strafe
gekriegt habe ich mich einfach so unwohl
meinem körper gefühlt habe was dann zum
glück daran lag dass ich anscheinend
laktose nicht so gut vertragen und
diesen helicobacter meinem magen hatte
und jetzt ist es ja auch eigentlich gut
ich hab ich bin dadurch ich habe es
geschafft ich bin zu ärzten gerannt auch
wenn sie mir gesagt haben ist nichts
habe ich nicht aufgegeben und bin immer
weiter dem nachgegangen und jetzt sollte
es mir eigentlich gut gehen jetzt ist
eigentlich der moment gekommen wo ich
gerne wollen würde dass ich sage immer
das leben durch sagt er das ist so schön
und es ist halt nicht der fall und das
zu akzeptieren es superschwer weil
ungefähr zum umzug hat es begonnen es
hat schon ein bisschen davor begonnen
aber zum umzug in diese wohnung habe ich
im februar meine erste richtige
panikattacke bekommen
es war so dass ich drei tage krank war
und im bett lag und am dritten tag hat
wohl meine arme taub oder haben sich
taub angefühlt und ich musste sie immer
kratzen damit sie damit ich mich
vergewissert dass es nicht so ist dass
sie halt noch gefühle haben und dann
habe ich immer gemerkt dass ich mich
total bedrückt und beengt gefühlt habe
in der wohnung und dachte ok ich muss
jetzt einmal raus gehen und frische luft
schnappen weil ich irgendwie hier gerade
durch drehen und dann habe ich
angefangen mich anzuziehen und durch die
erkältung oder grippe oder ich weiß man
sich hatte aber auf jeden fall war ich
halt so schwach habe mich angezogen und
habe gemerkt wie ich immer schneller aus
dieser wohnung raus gehen musste ich
musste dann ich hatte richtig das gefühl
wenn ich jetzt nicht rausgeht dann ich
kippe und werde hier sterben und dann
bin ich raus und bin gelaufen und es
wird nicht besser und die ganzen
menschen die auf der straße waren die
habe ich alle nervös gemacht und
irgendwann dachte ich aber zum glück
sind sie aber da weil wenn ich jetzt
gerade gleich um kippe dann dann kann
man ins krankenhaus bringen oder den
krankenwagen rufen und es endete so dass
ich selber den krankenwagen gerufen habe
weil ich erst mal taxi gerufen habe um
mich ins
zu bringen das hat aber fünf minuten
gebraucht das taxi bis zu mir und ich
habe gedacht dass ich das nicht schaffe
ich habe gedacht dass ich halt dann
sterbe wenn ich aufs taxi wartete und
dann hat mich der krankenwagen abgeholt
und sie haben gefragt ob sie mich
mitnehmen sollen und waren erstmal nicht
so sicher weil die gesagt haben die
alles ist gut so ich ag hat jetzt nichts
gezeigt aber falls es mich beruhigt oder
falls ich mir immer noch sorgen mache
oder falls er wirklich was ist wäre es
gut dass ich mitkommen und damit ich
mitgekommen
fast vier stunden in der notfallaufnahme
klar ich hab mich geblutet mir ging es
sehr gut dann werden sie definitiv
andere fälle vornehmen als mich aber
nach diesen vier stunden kam ein
psychotherapeut der mir halt nur zwei
teile in die hand gedrückt hat und
gesagt hat jung gedacht dass eine
panikattacke
hier sind nummern die duh anrufen kannst
und dann bin ich halt nach hause und ihr
müsst also verständlich sein von diesen
vier stunden ist in diesem
notfallaufnahme bereich alleine krank
ich habe teilweise dann mich so
hingelegt und habe versucht zu schlafen
weil ich so schlepper und ich bin nach
hause bin am nächsten tag aufgestanden
und habe mich für eine halbe stunde
wieder gut gefühlt und dann ging es
sofort wieder los und das ist ja panik
ich hatte panik aber es war nichts nix
da also in dem moment habe ich mich
nicht gefühlt als ob was wäre weil ich
war ja gerade quasi untersucht worden
und ich wusste es ist gerade nichts mir
geht es gut aber trotzdem hatte ich das
gefühl dass ich halt irgendwie sterben
werde
so jetzt junges hat dass das meinen
körper gerade durchdreht und ich konnte
mir das zu akzeptieren ist einfach
unmöglich dass du einfach sagt okay es
ist gerade eine angststörung der panik
das wird wieder vergehen wenn du ist an
diesem moment fühlst dann fühlst du es
so sehr dass das es sich es ist als ob
du gleich sterben müsstest und es ist so
sieht es ist so sieht es das ist das
überhaupt gibt und dann am nächsten tag
als ich gemerkt habe es wurde definitiv
nicht besser
da habe ich einfach das sinnvollste
gemacht was man in der situation tun
kann ich bin zu meinem hausarzt gegangen
und habe ihm die situation erklärt und
wie schlecht es mir geht und das gerade
wirklich einfach nicht klar komme und
dass ich hilfe brauche und er hat gesagt
das ist der gleiche arzt der mir auch
verschwiegen hat dass ich viele kuba
charaktere in meinem bauch habe also der
das faxgerät irgendwie ne das war ja
kaputt deswegen hatte ich die diagnose
erst so spät bekommen ich weiß jetzt
definitiv ich gehe nicht mehr zu diesem
arzt er hat mir gesagt dass ich über
ventiliert habt mit über ventilation auf
einen zettel geschrieben meinte googeln
sie das mal wo ich mir dachte also ich
weiß ja was hyperventilieren ist und
also als ob das ja was wäre was so sie
leiden daran ja auf jeden fall hat er
mir ein medikament verschrieben das
heißt da war und er hat gesagt das
drückt sie wenn sie es brauchen aber
jetzt nicht jeden tag zum frühstück
nehmen und nicht okay dann habe ich mit
meiner besten freundin darüber
gesprochen und ihr erzählt was passiert
ist und was jetzt bekommen habt und sie
arbeite in einer anstalt oder nicht
anstalt in einer wohngemeinschaft für
schizophrenie menschen und kennt sich
halt mit medikamenten aus und als er
gehört hat was ich bekommen ab da war
hat sie gleich gesagt wann es hat ihm
das nicht also wirklich nur wenn du
absolut nicht glaubst dass es nicht
anders geht dann vielleicht aber nimmt
das einfach nicht weil es macht dich es
wirklich abhängig machen und ich dachte
mir noch so ja komm also eigentlich
werde ich mich von sachen abhängig von
kaffee trinken und dann habe ich eine
genommen und es ging mir besser man als
zu hause war habe ich dann gleich nach
psychotherapeuten gesucht und nach einer
alternative also ich war schon bei der
psychotherapie und habe auch gute
erfahrungen damit aber ja ich wollte
einfach alles mögliche tun um so schnell
wie möglich aus dieser situation
rauszukommen und dann habe ich eine
hypnose therapie gefunden zu der ich
drei mal hingegangen bin können wir vier
mal gewesen sei diese hypnose therapie
hat mir so gut getan ich musste
allerdings zwei monate auf diesen termin
warten und ihr könnt euch vorstellen was
ich in diesen zwei monaten gemacht habe
ständig im bett gelegen weil die
panikattacken natürlich gekommen und
gegangen sind wie sie wollten und immer
schön da wahrgenommen wenn es schlimm
wurde und ratet mal wer es nicht mehr
lassen konnte tableau zu nehmen sobald
er gemerkt hat dass es schlimmer wird
ich habe mir dann noch mal gedanken über
das medikament gemacht und mir wurde
bewusst wie
schnell ich es genommen habt
beziehungsweise wurde mir auch bewusst
dass mein körper vielleicht symptome
auch simuliert um dieses medikament zu
kriegen wegen der körperlichen
abhängigkeit also habe ich relativ
schnell komplett wieder abgesetzt und
habe seitdem habe ich einmal noch mal
genommen lasst euch hier an dieser
stelle wirklich gesagt sein wenn euch
ein hausarzt das verschreibt ein
beruhigendes medikament seid euch
wirklich bewusst wie abhängig so was
machen kann und wie vorsichtig man damit
umgehen soll
mein arzt hat mir das nicht mal
ansatzweise so erklärt er hat nur gesagt
ja persönlich zum frühstück nehmen wenn
meine beste freundin nicht mir ganz klar
und deutlich gesagt hat was machen kann
und dann wäre ich nie auf die idee
gekommen dass wir das zeug schaden
könnte wenn man sich halt damit nicht
befasst mit dem thema dann denkt man so
ja ich habe jetzt was dagegen bekommen
und jetzt ist alles gut aber so ist es
nicht also habe ich zwei monate lang
höher
ich weiß gar nicht wie man am besten mit
dem zu dieser zeit beschreiben kann aber
es war eine mischung aus
ich stehe morgens auf versuche mein
leben so gut es geht zu meistern und und
meine aufgaben zu erfüllen und
gleichzeitig sitzt er die ganze zeit im
nacken dass du nicht okay ist und dass
irgendwas nicht stimmt und plötzlich
denkst du daran dass du wieder sterben
könntest sondern liegst du wieder im
bett und kann es nicht atmen und denkst
da habe ich noch mehr dass du sterben
könntest es war ein schlimmer
teufelskreis und dann kam - und das hat
mir so richtig wieder energie gegeben
und ich habe gedacht jetzt geht's los
jetzt wird alles besser und es wurde so
viel besser und mein gott
hypnosetherapie falls sich das leisten
können falls ihr das irgendwie in eurer
nähe machen könnt probiert es aus weil
es hat also klar man muss für hypnose
auch offen sein
es ist aber nicht so wie show hypnose
also da ist keiner der sich dann so
jetzt schläfst du das ist so ein richtig
ruhiges ambiente und du kommst da rein
und also du kannst auch jederzeit
abbrechen
das ist nicht so dass du im weg bist
oder keine kontrolle mehr hast du hast
über alles kontrolle ist einfach super
gut und sei das auch begonnen hat gehe
ich zu einer therapeutin und ja
versuche einfach mit der situation
klarzukommen wenn ich darüber nachdenke
woher das kommen kann
diese todesängste dieses wirklich reale
denken ich könnte jetzt sterben was nach
der hypnose deutlicher wurde also die
panikattacken sind ich mir so
ausgebrochen ich hab' ich habe mich
nicht mehr so verloren gefühlt aber
trotzdem habe ich eine reale angst
gehabt oder habe sie bis heute dass ich
sterben werde nicht immer gerade nicht
gerade denke ich das nicht aber dann
habe ich so für eine halbe stunde lang
hinziehen im herzen oder in der brust
und dann geht's schon los und dann denke
ich okay hoffentlich schaffe ich es noch
den krankenwagen zu rufen und das sind
gedanken die ich die rollen im kopf ohne
dass man es aushalten kann oder im
urlaub war ich und eigentlich war alles
schön ich saß da und war happy und ab
tag 3 war ich plötzlich wieder in diesem
käfig gefangen und an einem abend habe
ich muss ihn gegessen und habe mich
total gefreut und dachte jeder muscheln
einloggen und dann kam mir der gedanke
es gibt leute die krebstiere allergie
haben also muscheln shrimps sowas und
das hier wie bei erdnussallergie dass
der als extrem zu spielt und man daran
sterben kann so was glaubt ihr wer ganz
schnell wieder auf seinem zimmer war ich
könnte auch ganz lange hinter fragen
woran das liegt warum habe ich so angst
vorm tod und ganz ehrlich jeder hobby
psychologe hat jetzt schon die antwort
ich habe mein bruder hat sterben sehen
also fast zwei mal und ich meine ich war
14 und mein bruder war
16.15 und er wurde einfach so aus dem
leben gerissen und es war so ein glück
wer auf dem weg zur schule gewesen hätte
es nicht geschafft wer abends im bett
gewesen hätte es nicht geschafft wer er
keine ahnung auf dem klo gewesen hätte
es nicht geschafft er hat es nur
geschafft weil er weil es im unterricht
passiert ist und weil wir einen
schulsanitätsdienst damals hatten der
wirklich außergewöhnlich gute arbeit
geleistet hat und weil dann natürlich
auch schnell der krankenwagen gerufen
werden konnte und das waren nur diese
zufälle die dazu müssen wir das jetzt
geschafft hat und natürlich ist das in
mir drin geblieben und wahrscheinlich
deswegen mehr davon aus dass das leben
einfach so einem weggenommen werden kann
und ich habe aber nie so doll darüber
nachgedacht wie in der letzten zeit und
ich frage mich manchmal ob es mit dem
erfolg zu tun hat ich habe nämlich auch
ein kommentar gelesen dass also weil
jetzt meine wohnung gesehen habt und sie
ist wunderschön sie ist groß sie ist
toll ich liebe sie jetzt also
tatsächlich hat das reich ein bisschen
geheult also ich gut ich meine zeremonie
klar hilft da hab ich immer und diese
zeremonie ich fühle mich extrem wohl
auch an einer sich schon wieder auf dem
boden sitzen
ich weiß es ist ein richtiges buch ist
eine kuschelige wohnung aber das war in
meinem leben nicht der standard ich bin
nach berlin gekommen und habe erstmal in
dem elf quadratmeter zimmer gewohnt
es waren zehn oder elf quadratmeter in
der wg dann habe ich ein bisschen
größeres zimmer gehabt aber da hatte ich
die ganze zeit mäuse weil das halt voll
die abgegrenzte wohnung war dann hatte
ich noch eine wg und dann bin ich glaube
ich damals mit krone sondern bezogen bin
ich mir nicht mehr so sicher
auf jeden fall ist das so ein langsamer
prozess gewesen zu größeres zimmer ein
größeres zimmer eigene wohnung auf
eigene wohnung eigene supergeile wohnung
und in meinem leben gab es immer etwas
worüber ich mir sorgen machen konnte
über meine wohnsituation über meinen
finanziellen status was ich noch diesen
monat an essen kaufen kann
ob ich mir neue schuhe kaufen kann ich
bin nach berlin gekommen und habe die
ersten zweieinhalb jahre oder drei jahre
pinkl schuhe von aldi getragen und mein
größter wunsch war es ein cooles pass
niger zu haben
von nike oder adidas oder so ihr könnt
mir gerne spontan und dass ich hier
gelandet bin ist absolut wahnsinn ich
hätte es mir nicht mal in jahren
erträumt dass ich irgendwann mal meine
miete zahlen kann und mir nicht gedanken
machen muss ob ich werde noch genug geld
fürs essen habe und das ist jetzt so
gekommen ist muss ich mir tatsächlich
auch selber sagen das habe ich erreicht
das hat mir keiner gegeben
meine familie als ob zwar ziemlich kacke
ganz oft in meinem leben und ich habe es
trotzdem geschafft und ich bin sehr
stolz darauf
und dann ist es so furchtbar dass man es
nicht genießen kann
für mich so ich fühle mich so oft wie
ein versager weil mein kopf nicht so
will wie ich weil ich nicht gerne die
welt bereisen möchte und den machu
picchu sehen möchte oder nach australien
will oder so und ich weiß nicht ob es
ist weil ich da nicht wirklich hin
möchte oder ob ich einfach mal angst
davor habe aber angst
deshalb mein ständiger begleiter ja ich
habe mir den richtigen job ausgesucht
aber ich habe mir diesen job nicht
ausgesucht der job hat mich aufgesucht
ich wollte immer schauspielerin werden
und dann sind grund sprecherin
dann habe ich eigentlich mit meinem
umzug nach berlin habe ich akzeptiert so
ruhig wer derzeit einzelhandelskauffrau
bei büchner und finde das super und ich
liebe kunst und ich mag malen dann habe
ich meinen traum erreicht und jetzt bin
ich hier und seit ich mich im februar so
viele dachte ich darüber nach ein video
über dieses thema zu machen aber ich
habe immer darauf gewartet dass ich es
von der perspektive erzählen kann
wisst ihr damals da ging es mir voll
schlecht aber heute ist alles wieder
super und jetzt ist es über vier monate
später und es ist noch nicht super aber
das bedeutet nicht dass das leben nicht
schön ist das schlimmste ist halt
wirklich zu akzeptieren ja ich habe eine
panik und angst störung ja ich muss
manchmal auch situation raus wo jeder
denkt er ist doch super klasse hier
gerade was ist dein problem ja es fällt
mir schwer ins kino zu gehen wenn ich
mich in einem kinosessel sitze kriege
ich eine taube lippe ja ich kann nicht
überall hinreisen weil keine ahnung ich
angst habe ja ich schaffe nicht so viele
videos auf youtube wie ich gerne wollen
würde weil mein leben oftmals um daraus
besteht gerade
mit der situation klarzukommen anja es
könnte auch sein dass eine zeit in der
ich das kochbuch gemacht habe ich
vielleicht einen burn out bekommen habe
und dass mein körper mir jetzt
eigentlich nur vermitteln möchte haye
vanessa achte mal bitte besser auf dich
das ist nämlich auch eine theorie von
panikattacken dass sie einfach nur ein
warnsignal vom körper sind ich mein ich
liebe mein kochbuch und ich liebe es
dass ich es geschafft habe ich bin ich
kann nicht stolz darüber sein aber ich
habe das so viel zeit rein gesteckt und
so viel arbeit und so viel gedanken und
so viele schlaflose nächte und so viel
also es hat mir bestimmt etwas
weggenommen und ich muss ist wieder
kriegen und ich weiss ich kriege es
wieder ich weiß ich brauch nur geduld
aber ich hatte nicht das gefühl dass ich
jetzt einfach weitermachen kann und euch
so das vorleben dass ich so perfekt bin
und das wissen leben ist denn schon so
perfekt es gibt niemanden der der
wirklich so glücklich ist wer auf seinen
social media kanälen präsentiert und wir
wissen dass alle aber trotzdem lassen
wir uns alle ständig davon blenden und
trotzdem gleich mit dazu die dann nicht
ehrlich zu den leuten ist und einfach
auch mal so ein video macht und sagt ey
mir geht es wirklich gerade nicht gut
einfach nur weil ich angst um mein image
habt ich habe angst davor dass ihr mich
nicht als die lustige vanessa seht der
ihr gerne zuschaut und sie unterstützt
sondern dass ich für euch diese vanessa
bin ja ja die mit der angststörung und
die mit dem leben nicht so klar kommt
die andere weil alles halt auch irgendwo
ein geschäft ist hätte ich eine
pr-agentur hätte ich wahrscheinlich erst
mit der sprechen müssen ob es okay ist
dass ich das jetzt preisgeben
gestern habe ich ein video von einem
youtuber gesehen der viel mit
minimalismus und so macht und der auch
darüber gesprochen hat das längste und
ich glaube das war so der startpunkt für
mich dass ich das jetzt auch preisgebe
weil es sich so gut angefühlt zu wissen
dass selbst so ein youtube wie er den
ich bewundere für seine arbeit
dass der ja das gleiche hat wie ich habe
mich richtig verstanden gefühlt plätze
ich hab richtig gedacht
ich konnte jetzt nicht das nächste video
machen und und einfach so weitermachen
und ich werde jetzt weiter videos machen
und ich werde super happy sein beim ich
videos machen glücklich macht und ich
werde ich werde wieder zurück zu mir
finden und mein content machen den ihr
auch feiert und den ich feiere und ich
werde meinen weg gehen aber es ist
wichtig super wichtig zu sagen das leben
es wirklich nicht immer ein schüler in
der brust
prost wenn man über etwas sprechen muss
was einem am herzen liegt darf man auch
gerne dabei schwitzen musste gerade
mediapart denken
es fühlt sich gerade an wie eine million
fahrt video wenn es euch zur zeit so
geht wie mir akzeptiert diese situation
und akzeptiert euch wie ihr seid und
akzeptiert dass solche phasen kommen
können und habt euch lieb und habt keine
angst vorm tod der kommt sicher ich bin
gespannt ob ich dieses video auch
wirklich online stelle
[Musik]
si